vous avez posé la question de qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait dire à un jeune
palestinien j'aimerais l'a renversée et
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait dire un jeune
israélien
je pense que la question qu'il faudrait
poser d'abord c'est demander vous en
tant que jeune israélien qu'est ce qu'un
jeune palestinien connaît la démocratie
israélienne
qu'avez vous montrer à ses grands
parents à ses parents de ce que c'est
que la démocratie israélienne
rien un habitant de gaza de naplouse ne
connaît rien la démocratie israélienne
tout ce qu'il a vu de 1948 c'est des
expulsions des expropriations une
colonisation une occupation militaire
une soldatesque des droits qui ne sont
jamais respectées
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé du statu
quo et monsieur dickov l'a bien expliqué
j'ajouterai encore plus c'est que le
statu quo n'existe pas dans ce conflit
même si les médias s'en emparent quand
il ya une explosion de violences comme
celles là le cas mais le reste de
l'année on a des attaques de colons
contre des paysans palestiniens on a des
affrontements entre les populations
on a une colonisation qui progresse on a
des expropriations
monsieur gumienny tout à l'heure a
rappelé quelques quelques éléments il a
évoqué au milieu en israël on s'est
retirée du liban et on a eu le hesbollah
d'accord c'est une réalité mais pas
ignorer que audi bon aujourd'hui vous
avez à peu près 200 mille palestiniens
dans des camps de réfugiés dans des
conditions déplorables et ça évidemment
c'est la faute en partie des états
arabes mais qui attendent que israël
respecte le droit international depuis
1948 ces populations là vous avez vous
retiré l'armée du liban elle n'en sont
pas pour autant complètement désabusé de
continuer à vivre dans un déni de droit
le plus total dans la bande de gaza
c'est pareil aujourd'hui on le sait bien
et vous êtes analyse vous savez aussi
bien que moi je pense lorsqu'on se
retire unilatéralement d'un territoire
et donc pas dans le cas d'une
négociation qui on favorise les plus
radicaux les plus extrémistes parce
qu'on fait croire à la population que
c'est grâce aux radicaux et à leurs
actes qu'ils ont mené que l'armée au
d'ennemis ou l'armée au d'opposition
s'est retiré donc il serait savez très
bien et sharon savez très bien que le
hamas elle sortirait grand vainqueur du
retrait de la bande de gaza il n'y a pas
d'égalité entre les populations de la
méditerranée au jourdain et vous aurez
beau faire tout ce que vous voulez
unilatéralement tant que ce fait ne sera
pas reconnu y aura encore des moments de
tension et des moments de colère tous
les 5 10
ou 15 ans
[Musique]